we begin this morning with the home
stretch of the presidential race on the
last weekend of campaigning
the candidates are sweeping out across
the most hotly contested states
joe biden is in michigan today and he'll
be joined by former president barack
obama
biden's running mate senator kamala
harris makes three stops in florida
meanwhile vice president mike pence
visits the upper midwest today
he'll be campaigning in wisconsin and
president trump holds
four rallies in pennsylvania the
keystone state is seen as the key
to the election with 20 electoral votes
up for grabs both campaigns have been
pushing hard there
in the closing days of the race last
night the president held a socially
distanced rally
in minnesota a state he's hoping to add
to his column
after narrowly losing it in 2016. the
last minute campaigning comes as the u.s
hit another
record high for coronavirus infections
in a single day
again on friday when nearly a hundred
thousand new cases
were reported paula reed kicks off our
coverage from minneapolis this morning
paula good morning good morning michelle
in these last few days before the
election president trump is hitting
these
key battleground states but many of
these states are also
coveted hot spots including here in
minnesota where last night
the state's governor restricted the size
of the president's event
as the state hit a record in new covid
cases
hello rochester president trump hammered
the state's democratic governor for
limiting his rally to just
250 supporters following covet outbreaks
tied to two previous rallies held there
there are at least 25 000 people who
wanted to be here tonight they were here
for a long time they waited and waited
and
then the governor did bad things with
kovid raging
in every swing state he hit friday the
president still
tried to downplay the virus it's a
pandemic and you're doing good
but in michigan a state he carried in
2016
and now trails biden by eight points
covet hospitalizations are up 96
since october first it's always cases
are up and people go crazy you know
now it's uh you live with it and you
have
and you know what to do we understand it
now you're going to understand it
but we're making that beautiful turn mr
trump tried to undermine confidence in
the death toll
by falsely suggesting doctors
intentionally over report
covid deaths you know our doctors get
more money if somebody dies from kelvin
that's true
it's like two thousand dollars more so
you get more money
the president's rally in green bay was
criticized by the local hospital system
which warned it was a bad idea given the
city has one of the highest infection
rates in the nation
no i don't at all no and they're outdoor
rallies
they're all out to her the president's
attempts to downplay the virus are
undermined by evidence from the cdc
cbs news has learned cdc data shows
cases are
surging in 49 states on a call with
state governors
coronavirus task force member dr debra
burks
warned we're seeing now on surge across
the northern part of the united states
we now have about 1200 counties almost a
third of the country
in our hot spot category
today president trump will make four
stops in pennsylvania
a pivotal swing state that he won in
2016
but recent polls show him trailing
former vice president joe biden
jeff paula thank you very much